pitching one and two on a year also
making his fifth start will be the
right-hander jose barrios
so here we go game two and jose barrios
comes out firing and whitmerfield
comes up swinging
and a good start whit
will be at second base with nobody out
he was o for three in game one four and
that loads him up and here comes michael
franco
came back to strike him out and the
royals leave the bases full in the first
danny duffy makes his fifth start of the
year and his second straight start
against minnesota
the 3-2 pitch of swinging a fly ball
into right field deep solaire going back
still going still going jumps up makes
the catch on the track
garber tags and scores as polanco makes
third twins take a one-nothing lead on
the sac fly rbi for marvin gonzalez
the royals catcher cam gallagher
and he's running and there's a line
drive into right center field and
that'll get nikki lopez to third
and the royals have runners at the
corners with one out in the top of the
order coming up wit's double was on the
first pitch of the game and he went
right up the right field line
and whit lines it into right center
field that'll tie the game
gallagher will stop at second base
and whitmer field is two for two they're
trying to come in on him there's a
little bit of a mistake there but 94 in
the middle whitt knows exactly what to
do with it watch the hand position head
position everything stays inside great
stroke he is a good golfer that looks
like he's on a golf tee right there
nicely done rios to lopez low ball four
boy that is a good played appearance by
nikki lopez that's number three for
barrios here is gallagher who had a base
hit to right field his first time up
here's the pitch
slider away ball four
i thought he would go with the fastball
i didn't think he wanted to face wood
merrifield whitmer field who already has
two hits today against barrios
swung on and hit well deep to left
that's a way back and that's a goner
like we said
he didn't want to pitch to whit
meritfield he threw a slider on a 3-2
count to cam gallagher and whit field
comes up and smacks a three-run home run
the royals lead it 4-1 and now this game
too he's saying you know what i'm going
to be aggressive and i'm going to be the
guy who i am be ready for that look like
a little change-up is what that was it
was a change of the state right in the
middle floated there and he barreled it
merrifield not messing around
a high fly to center field merrifield
going back there's that sound again off
the facing of the restaurant in center
field
and the twins answer right away with
another nelson cruz home run
got a high fastball
watch the barrel come right back at the
ball
and he knew it
absolutely knew it straight away center
field
doesn't matter when you hit it 440 feet
[Applause]
and now
he hit polanco and that puts him aboard
for cruz a breaking ball
and polanco doesn't get a walk but he
gains first base nelson cruz is homered
in both games of the double header and
he comes up representing the tying run
now the o2 and it's a fastball and he's
swung and missed and he strike up josh
stalmont he gets cruz
with a fastball up perfect pitch in that
situation against the power hitter
so a hit batter and a strikeout and now
here's switch hitting
marwin gonzalez batting left-handed
[Applause]
and that fastball is hit high in the air
to right field
and right at the wall whit merrifield is
there to make the play
oh man
man gonzalez he is not an easy out so
here's ceno
and here it comes he got him strike
three ninety-eight
and cenella strikes out swinging and
stalmont is tough yet again
trevor rosenthal
is four out of four
and save opportunities
and now a lead off one rosenthal now
will pitch to buxton over two
yep
three fastballs and down he goes and
that's one out in the seventh inning
jake cave is the scheduled hitter
rosen's already in comes a pitch and a
fast ball is swung on and missed
so now eddie rosario will pinch it
got him 100 miles an hour
so the royals
split the double header today both games
had the final score of four to two